kimberly is with us in san bernardino
california hi kimberly how are you
good hi dave i had a question um
me and my husband are kind of debating
um
our question is should my husband take a
new job
and depending on the retirement we don't
know a lot about retirement so we don't
know the questions that we should ask
he currently has a job where he has a
tier one and tier two that he pays him
to he works for the railroad
so the new job from what we know
that he was offered does not offer
retirement but they match six percent
i don't know what questions to ask to
make a wife's choice
okay um well i mean if if they're
if they have a 401k that they match in
six percent that sounds like a fairly
normal company type position
versus the railroad which has a very
unusual retirement system
okay okay so what does your husband make
at the railroad
he you want to know hourly no annually
okay i have the paper in front of me so
annually
um i don't okay so annually it shows i
don't think it has one here
so i'm thinking around what does he
bring what's he bring home a month or a
week or whatever
okay so he gets paid every two weeks
about
twenty one hundred dollars one thousand
after ten
yes twenty one hundred dollars and so
forty two hundred dollars a month
so forty eight thousand dollars a year
and so he's making about sixty sixty
five
000 depending on what's coming out of
his chat okay
correct okay now what's the new job pay
25 an hour so whatever that is times 80
times i don't know what that is
but um 50 grand okay thank you a guy in
the lobby just helped me all right
so uh you're gonna make about the same
or a little bit more
at the new job okay right okay now the
question here though is
how old is he my husband's 30.
okay so when he's 60 old like me
what's he going to be glad he spent the
last 30 years doing
which one of these what i think
saving for retirement paying off no no
no no no no no that wasn't what i was
talking about
can't can this is yours yeah so here's
the thing
we've got the numbers right he's making
60 to 65 now on the railroad
this new job is going to pay him about
50. so it's a pay cut
if we got those numbers right so that's
the first issue but
what dave was asking is why does this
guy want this job why does your husband
want the job does he want it because he
loves the work
it's it's work that matters to him in
long term he's the railroad yeah why is
he what the
what's the what's the reason for the new
job with the railroad he can't go up
anymore so that's the top okay good so
he's captain
good job yes correct so with the new job
he does start off at 25 but after three
to six months he goes back to 32.
there we go now now we're moving the
right direction so this is a temporary
pay cut
for the opportunity to advance not just
financially but also professional
what would he be doing at the new job um
so far what i know it's called the
operator d
so it's borax i don't know if you guys
ever heard of borax it's called boron
rio tinto
so they um it's a mine and they do
minerals
so he would be packaging shipping out
minerals
everything to do with uh it's not
under the ground mine it's above the
ground it has to do with the minerals
they put in electronics
when he talks to you when he talks to
you about it what do you think his
excitement level is
sorry what do you think his excitement
level is when you hear him talk to you
about this new job
on a scale of one to ten one no
excitement ten he's throwing a party
what's his excitement level when he
talks to you about this new job
10. then it's a no-brainer so you guys
don't
need to plan for the short term not
retirement listen
listen you take the 401k you get out of
debt you do your baby steps
maybe step three is in place of three to
six months of expenses you're debt-free
and then you put 15 percent of your
income away for retirement and you will
retire wealthy
15 you need to put 15
of your income away for retirement and
they're going to match another six
and so you're going to retire wealthy if
you do that
okay so you're fine you're not you're
not you are not
going to retire and have to eat alpo
that's right okay
good now here's here's the other thing
never take a job
ever ever just for the money never take
a job
ever because of the freaking benefits
package that's true
always take a job because it has a
bright
future and makes you smile doing the
work
yes this is the way you make a decision
on a job
not based on the freaking 401k match
that's exactly right now
let's go back into our baby steps dave
let's walk let's walk other people
through this because this call
we get this a lot on the ken coleman
show i know a lot of people listening
watching right now
are feeling this too so this is a
temporary pay cut okay
so in three to six months he's gonna go
from 25 an hour to around 32 an hour
so they need to get back into their
budget and go okay we have to plan
for a temporary pay cut but it's
temporary so we got to adjust the budget
we plan for this and we absorb this your
thoughts on that yeah absolutely
absolutely don't act like it's not
happening yeah because they only end up
you know i ran up five thousand dollars
in credit card debt yeah we took a pay
cut
you know that's just that's dumber than
a rock don't do that so you got to plan
it it's going to happen
it's going to happen so plan on the drop
in pay make sure you're going to br
lower your lifestyle to fit that
and then you can then you can begin your
investing process later but
yeah railroad retirement is incredible
it is
not so incredible that you should keep a
job making
absolute ceiling on your ability to
progress
and keep a job that you don't like doing
yeah this is important to point out
that you know when it's time to consider
moving on when you
have been told and it's been made
obvious to you that you've hit your lid
now you've got to sit back and go okay
am i okay with this lid because dave you
know this we as humans are creatures of
progress it's just
wired into us by our creator we want to
make progress we want to grow
some people have gone so far as to say
if you're not growing if you're not
learning you're dying
now you there are some jobs where you go
hey this is it
and i'm good here and this is it but for
those of you who want more in your work
and you're in an environment where
because of the organization or the
leadership there is an artificial lid on
you you're not moving up
it's time to start thinking about moving
on
that'll wear on you